mitwirkende bei diesem gottesdienst ganz
anders als sonst bei den
osterfeierlichkeiten wenn zehntausende
menschen auf dem petersplatz gemeinsam
mit dem papst ostern feiern
doch die korona pandemie zwingt auch den
papst ostern 2020 anders zu feiern als
sonst
der gottesdienst beginnt mit einem
lateinischen hymnus einem lobgesang der
zu ostern gesungen wird aus dem 15
jahrhundert profile et le
er reflektiert die botschaft das
geschehen von ostern
[Musik]
die christen sind hocherfreut der herr
der ewigen herrlichkeit ist von dem tod
erstanden heute in die frauen kamen zu
dem ort wo jesus salben dort wer welt
den stein vom grabe fort halleluja die
jünger früh am dritten tag sehen
ängstlich an der stätte nach wo jesus
christ begraben lag
[Musik]
der liebste juni st johann er eilt dem
petrus schnell voran kam früher bei dem
graben ein engel strahlt dem licht
gewarnt den frommen frauen macht
bekanntes jesus christus auferstand
halleluja
[Musik]
bleibt nicht beim bärengraben stehen
jetzt sollte nach galiläa gehen dort
werdet jeden meisters in den jüngern
war das herz so schwer in ihrer mitte
trat der herr der friede sei mit euch
sagt er
sie sahen den herrn von angesicht doch
voller zweifel thomas spricht wenn ich
nicht viel glaube ich nicht
halleluja
[Musik]
sie thomas sie die seite an sie hände
und füße male dran im und glaube doch
was gott getan halleluja namen des
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geistes
der friede sei mit euch liebe schwestern
und brüder damit wir die heiligen
geheimnisse in rechter weise feiern
können und wir bekennen dass wir
gesündigt haben
ich bekenne gott dem allmächtigen und
allen brüdern und schwestern dass ich
gutes unterlassen und böses getan habe
ich habe gesündigt den gedanken worten
und werken ich meine schuld durch meine
schule durch meine große schuld
doch unbedingt die selige jungfrau maria
alle engel und heiligen und euch brüder
und schwestern für mich zu bieten bei
pot und zum herrn der allmächtige gott
erbarme dich unser lasst uns die sünde
nach und für uns zum ewigen leben kamen
[Musik]
in der höhe und friede auf erden den
menschen seiner gnade wir preisen dich
hier bieten sich an
wir bringen dich
[Musik]
und danken dir denn groß ist deine
herrlichkeit
[Musik]
herr und gott könig des sinnes gott und
vater die herrscher über das all ein
geborener sohn jesus christus
herr und gott
lamm gottes
[Musik]
sohn des vaters
du nimmst hinweg die sünde der welt
[Musik]
erbarme dich unser
im stil weg die sünde der welt nehmen an
unser gebiet
[Musik]
bussis ist zur echten des vaters erbarme
dich unser
[Musik]
wenn du allein bis der heilige
du allein der herr
[Musik]
du allein der höchste jesus christus mit
dem heiligen geist zur ehre gottes des
vaters
[Musik]
amen
lasst uns beten allmächtiger ewiger gott
am heutigen tag hast du dich deinen sohn
besiegt und uns den zugang zum ewigen
leben erschlossen
warum begehen wir in freude das fest
seiner auferstehung schaffe uns neu
durch deinen geist damit auch wir
auferstehen und endlich des lebens
wandeln
darum bieten wir durch jesus christus
teilen sohn unseren herrn und gott der
in der einheit des heiligen geistes mit
der liebt und herrscht in alle ewigkeit
amen
nach dem eröffnungs teil des
gottesdienstes folgen nun die texte aus
der bibel lesung aus der
apostelgeschichte in jenen tagen begann
petrus zu reden und sagte ihr wisst was
im ganzen land der losen geschehen ist
angefangen in galiläa nach der taufe die
johannes verkündet hat jesus von
nazareth gesendet hat mit dem heiligen
geist und mit kraft dieser umher zog
gute start und alle halte die in der
gewalt des teufels waren
denn gott war mit ihm und wir sind
zeugen für alles was er im land der
juden und in jerusalem getan hat ihn
haben sie an den pfahl gehängt und
getötet gott aber hat ihn am dritten tag
auf erweckt und hat ihn erscheinen
lassen
zwar nicht dem ganzen volk wohl aber den
von gott vorherbestimmten zurück und die
wir mit ihm nach seiner auferstehung von
den toten gegessen und getrunken haben
und er hat uns geboten dem volk zu
verkündigen und zu bezeugen
das ist der von gott eingesetzten
richter der lebenden und der toten von
ihm bezeugen alle propheten dass jeder
der an ihn glaubt durch seinen namen die
vergebung der sünden empfängt dank sei
gott
[Musik]
der antwort psalm 118
antwortet führt ihn von der lesung zum
evangelischen das ist der tag den der
herr gemacht haus
[Musik]
wir wollen google und uns über ihn
freuen
[Musik]
danke dem herrn denn hier ist gut
seine holt wird ewig so soll israel
sagen denn seine huld werte ewig
[Musik]
die rechte des herrn sie erhöht die
rechte des herrn paten der machtvoll
prinzip ich werde nicht sterben sondern
leben und die taten des herrn zu
verkünden
[Musik]
das carport
da standen die bauleute verwarfen iris
zum werksteil geworden
vom herrn hier ist dies gewährt
ein bunte in unseren augen
ok
[Musik]
lesung aus dem brief des apostels paulus
an die gemeinde in kolosse schwestern
und brüder seit er nun mit christus
auferweckt so strebt nach dem was oben
ist wo christus zur rechten gottes sitzt
richtet euren sinn auf das wasser ist
nicht auf das irdische ihr seid
gestorben und euer leben ist mit
christus verborgen in gott wenn christus
unser leben offenbar wird dann werdet
auch ihr mit ihm offenbar werden in
herrlichkeit ort des lebendigen gottes
dank sei gott
es folgt nun eine alte sequenz die das
osterlamm den auferstandenen preist das
lob dem osterlamm bringt er sie daher
christen
[Musik]
aslam erlöst die schafe christus der
ohne schuld war
versöhnte die sünder mit dem vater tod
und leben die kämpfen unbegreiflichen
zweikampf des lebens fürst der stab
herrscht nun lebend maria magdalena sag
uns was hast du gesehen
[Musik]
mit dem österlichen halleluja wird das
evangelium vom leben begrüßt
[Musik]
o
der pass salam ist geopfert christus so
lasst uns das festmahl feier in dem
herrn
halleluja
[Musik]
das evangelium wird zunächst in
lateinischer sprache
und dann noch einmal auf griechisch
verkündet
[Musik]
domino sowie herrn sei mit euch und mit
deinem geist
[Musik]
aus dem heiligen evangelium nach
johannes
[Musik]
teil der woche kam maria von magdala
früh marx und sah dass der stein sie
schnell zu sehen und petrus und dem sie
haben den herren aus dem grab genommen
und wir wissen nicht wohin sie ihn
gelegt haben
[Musik]
petrus und der andere jünger hinaus und
haben
[Musik]
sie liefen beide zusammen aber der
andere jünger schneller war als petrus
kam er als erster ans grab in sah die
leinenbinden titel ging jedoch nicht
hinein
[Musik]
da kam auch simon petrus der gefolgt war
und gingen das grab hinein
[Musik]
gegen das schweißtuch das auf dem haupt
jesu gelegen hatte es lag aber nicht bei
den leinenbinden sondern
zusammengebunden daneben an einer
besonderen stelle
[Musik]
da ging auch der andere jünger der als
erste an das grab gekommen war hinein
usa und glaubte
[Musik]
sie hatten noch nicht die schrift
verstanden dass wir von den toten
auferstehen müssen
[Musik]
evangelium unseres herrn jesus christus
sei dir christus
[Musik]
es folgt das evangelium nun noch einmal
auf griechisch der ursprache der
evangelien er beginnt mit einem dialog
zwischen dem diakon und dem papst
weisheit aufrecht lasset uns hören das
heilige evangelium der friede sei mit
allen die gemeinde antwortet und mit
deinem geiste aus dem heiligen
evangelium nach johannes
ehre sei dir herr ihre seite
[Musik]
lasset uns auf merken die verkündigung
des evangeliums in typisch
[Musik]
brigitte proß simon martin ohne der gfds
mateja die partie plätschert im moment
[Musik]
ich hätte und simona pedrosa colorado
die story hat ihm ein tattoo studio ohne
ballack co
[Musik]
dort los ist
sda
wie die gfk
o
[Musik]
anna-lena
die gemeinde antwortet auf die
verkündigung ehre sei dir herr ehre sei
dir
[Musik]
der papst segnet mit dem evangelium die
gemeinde
[Musik]
der chor singt auf griechisch auf viele
jahre heiliger vater
in den ostergottesdiensten folgt an
dieser stelle normalerweise die predigt
der papst verzichtet darauf weil er
nachher beim segen urbi et orbi seine
osterbotschaft den menschen in der stadt
und im ganzen erdkreis verkünden wird
es folgt das glaubensbekenntnis wir
glauben an den einen gott den vater den
allmächtigen er alles geschaffen hat
himmel und erde die sichtbare und die
unsichtbare welt
und an dem einen herrn jesus christus
gottes eingeborenen sohn aus dem vater
geboren vor aller zeit
[Musik]
gott von gott licht vom licht wahrer
gott vom wahren gott
[Musik]
bezeugt nicht geschaffen eines wesens
mit dem vater durch ihn ist alles
geschaffen
für uns menschen und zu unserem heil ist
der vom himmel gekommen
[Musik]
hat fleisch angenommen durch den
heiligen geist von der jungfrau maria
und ist mensch geworden er wurde für uns
gekreuzigt und herr pontius pilatus hat
gelitten und ist begraben worden
[Musik]
ist am dritten tage auferstanden nach
der schrift und aufgefahren in den
himmel
er sitzt zur rechten des vaters und wird
wieder kommen in herrlichkeit zu richten
die lebenden und die toten seiner
herrschaft wird kein ende sein
[Musik]
wir glauben an den heiligen geist der
herr ist und lebendig macht
der aus dem vater und dem sohn hervor
geht er mit dem vater und dem sohn an
gebiet und verherrlicht wird
[Musik]
der gesprochen hat durch die profite
und die eine heilige katholische und
apostolische kirche
[Musik]
wir bekennen die eine taufe zur
vergebung der sünden
[Musik]
wir erwarten die auferstehung der toten
und das ewige leben
[Musik]
amen
nach dem credo dass die zentralen
inhalte des christlichen glaubens
zusammenfasst folgt nur das für bittende
gebiet die bruder und schwester in der
freude über den sieg christi über die
sünde und tod erheben wir vertrauensvoll
unser gebet zum herrn lasst uns zum
herrn bieten wir bitten dich erhöre uns
lasst uns beten für die heilige kirche
gottes die österliche gnade lasse die
kirche in neuer schönheit erstrahlen
dass sie starken glauben freudig in der
liebe und beharrlich in der hoffnung
alle zur begegnung mit dem
auferstandenen und lebendigen herrn
führe
lasset zum herrn uns beten wir bitten
dich
[Musik]
ist uns bieten für alle die politische
verantwortung tragen
das strahlende licht der helle die
entscheidungen der regierenden dass sie
sich frei von allen kompromissen mit dem
bösen im aufbau einer zivilisation der
liebe widmen lasse zum herrn uns bieten
wir bitten dich
[Musik]
lasst uns beten für die armen und
bedrängten der reichtum österlicher
klagen gaben werde den armen und
bedrängten im überfluss zu teilen dass
sie sich von elend not und angst befreit
an der fülle des lebens erfreuen können
lasset zum herrn uns beten wir bitten
dich erhöre uns
[Musik]
lasst uns beten für alle getauften
lastern ausgehende lieben erreiche alle
getauften dass sie gestärkt durch den
leib und das blut christi
das verlangen nach heiligkeit
wiederentdecken und freude daran finden
lasst uns zum herrn bieten wir bitten
dich erhöhung
[Musik]
lasst uns beten für die kranken und
sterbenden
der österliche sieg über das böse und
über den tod tröste die kranken die
sterbenden und diejenigen die ihnen
beistehen
dass sie gestärkt durch die nähe ihrer
brüder und schwestern auf jesus den
auferstandenen und lebendigen vertrauen
lasse zum herrn uns beten wir bitten
dich erhöre uns
[Musik]
historiker
mit den fürbitten geht der wort gottes
teil der ostermesse zu ende
diakone
zehn jahre bringen die gaben zum altar
so dass der zweite große hauptteil der
messe beginnen kann der eucharistische
teil
[Musik]
der papst feiert im gottesdienst nicht
am großen papstaltar des petersdoms
sondern am sogenannten kathedra alltag
wer ganz vorne in der apsis des
petersdoms steht
[Musik]
er hat seinen namen von der kathedra
petri der tradition nach ein lehrstuhl
des apostels petrus er stammt allerdings
aus dem
neunten jahrhundert
[Musik]
o
euro
[Musik]
an die stelle des kreuzes tritt in der
osterzeit die osterkerze ein wichtiges
zeichen für den
auferstandenen christus dessen liebe und
nähe
für uns menschen brennt
[Musik]
sie bietet brüder und schwestern dass
mein und europa gott dem allmächtigen
vater gefallen der helme das wort fan
aus deinen händen zum not und ohne
seines namens zum siegen für uns und
seine ganze heilige kirche unser gott
neben die gaben an die wir in höchster
freude da bringen für das opfer durch
das deine kirche auf wunderbare weise
wiedergeboren und gestärkt wird sie in
christus unserem herren in wahrheit ist
es würdig und recht die ihr vater immer
und überall zu danken
diesen tag aber aufs höchste zu feiern
unser osterlamm käufer dieses jesus
christus
denn er ist das wahre lahm dass die
sünde der welt hinweg für seinen ton
hatte unseren tod vernichtet und ich
seine auferstehung neu geschaffen
darum jubelt heute der ganzen erdkreis
in österlicher freude darum reißen sich
die himmlischen mächte und die chöre der
engel und singen das lob deine
herrlichkeit
[Musik]
heilig heilig heilig gut herr alle
mischt und gewalt
[Musik]
erfüllt sind himmel und erde von deine
herrlichkeit hosanna in der höhe
[Musik]
hoch gelobt sei der da kommt im namen
des herrn
[Musik]
hosanna die dafür
so
[Musik]
die gütige vater mit mir durch deinen zu
unseren herrn jesus christus in dieser
heiligen makellosen opfergaben an und es
segne sie
wir bringen sie da vor allem für eine
heilige katholische kirche gemeinschaft
sie mir den du zum vorsteher einer
kirche berufen hass und mit allen die
sorge tragen für den rechten
katholischen und apostolischen glaubens
in einer kirche frieden und einheit und
leitet sie auf der ganzen erde gedenke
deine diene und dienerinnen und alle die
hier versammelt sind
herr du kennst ihren glauben und ihre
hingabe für sie bringen wir dieses opfer
des lobes tat und sich selber weil es
dir für sich und für alle die ihnen
familien sind für ihre erlösung und für
ihre hoffnung auf das unverlierbare heim
den ewigen lebendigen und wahrenburg
bringen sie ihre gebiete und gaben
gemeinschaft mit der ganzen kirche
verlieren wir das hochfest der
auferstehung unseres herrn jesus
christus gedenkt in deiner heiligen und
ihren vor allem maria die glorreiche als
jungfräuliche mutter unseres herrn und
gottes jesus christus er in ihren
bräutigam den heiligen josef deiner
heiligen apostel und märtyrer
petrus und paulus andreas johannes
thomas
[Musik]
liga auf ihr heiliges leben und sterben
und gewehre und so ihre fürsprache in
allem einen schutz um deine hilfe
ledige an oh gott dies gaben deine diene
und deiner ganz gemeinde
wir bringen sie da auch für jene die an
diesem osterfest aus dem wasser und dem
heiligen geist zum neuen leben geboren
wurden
denen du alles sünden vergeben hast
ordne unsere tag in deinem frieden rette
uns vor dem verderben wir uns auf in die
scharte einer erwählt schenk oh gott
diesen gaben siegen den früheren dem sie
zu eigen machen sie uns zum wahren opfer
im geist dass dir wohl gefällt eines
geliebten sohnes unseres herrn jesus
christus am abend vor seinem leiden name
das protein seiner heiligen und
ehrwürdigen händel erhob die augen zum
himmel zu dir seinem vater den
allmächtigen gott sagte dialog und lang
brach das brot reichte es seinen jüngern
und sprach nämlich und es wird alle
davon
das ist mein leib der für euch
cottbus
diebe zunahme nach dem mahl diesen
erhabenen kelchen seiner heiligen und
ehrwürdigen hände sagte dir lob und dank
reichte den kelch seinen jüngern sprach
nehmen und trinken alle daraus das ist
der kelch des neuen und ewigen bundes
meint blut das für euch und für alle
vergossen wird zur vergebung der sünden
tut dies zu meinem gedächtnis
[Musik]
geheimnis des glaubens der tool o herr
verkünden wir und deiner auferstehung
preisen
bist du kommst in herrlichkeit
[Musik]
darum gütiger vater von jeder eine
diener und ein heiliges volk das
gedächtnis deines sohnes unseres herrn
jesus christus verkünden sein heil sein
heil bringende sliden seiner
auferstehung von den toten und seine
glorreiche himmelfahrt
so bringen wir aus den gaben die du uns
geschenkt hast jedem erhabenen gott dir
eine und makellose opfergabe da das pro
des lebens und den kelch des ewigen
heils die gefäße endgültig darauf nieder
und nehmen sie an der einst die gabe
eines gerechten dieners abel das opfer
unseres vaters abraham die heilige gaben
das reine opfer eines hohen priester
tätig wir bitten dich allmächtiger gott
da eine heilige engel trage dieser opfer
gab auf deinen himmlischen althoff oder
eine göttliche herrlichkeit und wenn wir
durch unsere teilnahme am altar den
heiligen leib und das blut eines sohnes
empfangen
der fluence mit aller gnade und allem
segen des himmels
ich denke herr auch deine die
dienerinnen die uns voran gegangen sind
bezeichnet dem siegel des glaubens die
nun ruhen in frieden
wir bitten dich führe sie und alle die
in christus sind schlafen sind in das
land der verheißung des lichtes und des
friedens
auch uns deine sünden dienen die auf
deine reiche barmherzigkeit hoffen dem
anteil und gemeinschaft mit einem
heiligen apostel und märtyrer
um hier eine innovative erwarten aber es
werde ich sagen
marcellino petrelli zitate petersilie
wege nicht unser verdienst sondern
schenkel gnädig verzeihung und gibt uns
mit ihnen das erbe des himmels darum
bitten wir dich durch unseren haaren
jesus christus
denn durch ihn erschaffst du immer fort
altis guten gaben gibst dein leben und
weyhe und spendete uns durch ihn und mit
ihm und in ihm ist dir gott allmächtiger
vater in der einheit des heiligen
geistes alle herrlichkeit und ihre jetzt
und in ewigkeit
[Musik]
dem board und herren der lüschers
gehorsam und getreu seiner göttlichen
weißen wagen wir zu sprechen
[Musik]
vater unser im himmel geheiligt werde
dein name dein reich komme
[Musik]
dein wille geschehe die im himmel so auf
erden
[Musik]
unser tägliches brot gib uns heute und
vergib uns unsere schuld wie auch wir
vergeben unseren schuldigern und führe
uns nicht in versuchung sondern erlöse
uns von dem bösen
[Musik]
erlöse uns herr allmächtiger vater von
allem bösen und frieden in unseren tagen
kommen zur hilfe mit deinem erbarmen und
bewahre uns vor verjährung und sünde
damit wir voll zuversicht dass kommen
unseres erlösers jesus christus erwartet
denn dein ist das reich und die kraft
und die herrlichkeit in ewigkeit amen
[Musik]
der herr hat sozusagen der posten es
sagt frieden hinterlasse ich euch meinen
frieden gebe ich euch das erleiden wir
herr jesus christus schauen nicht auf
unsere sünden sondern auf den glauben
der kirche und schenkt dir nach deinem
willen einheit und frieden der du liebst
und herbst sind alle ewigkeit
der friede des herrn sei alle zeit mit
euch und mit einem geist
[Musik]
lamm gottes
nun ist hinweg die sünde der welt mit
ich uns
[Musik]
lamm gottes du nimmst hinweg die sünde
der welt
[Musik]
erbarme dich unser
oho
[Musik]
lamm gottes du nimmst hinweg die sünde
der welt
[Musik]
gib uns deinen frieden
die zehn allein negativ und sitzt das
lamm gottes das sind wegnehmen die sünde
der welt herr ich bin nicht würdig dass
du hingehst untermain dach aber spricht
nur ein wort so wird meine ziele gesummt
seelig die die zum hochzeitsmahl des
lammes geladen sind
[Musik]
unser osterlamm ist geopfert christus
der herr halleluja
so lasst uns festmahl halten in freude
halleluja halleluja halleluja
[Musik]
der chor meditiert in seinem gesang das
oster ereignis für die gemeinde ist es
in zeiten von corona nicht möglich die
konsequente host ihr selbst zu empfangen
aber es gibt die möglichkeit einer
geistigen kommunion der papst ein
bischof einen priester empfängt die
heilige kommunion und lässt aber daran
und dabei auch alle menschen teilhaben
die daran teilhaben wollen
ich kenne das selbst von mir dass ich
das sehr gerne mache auch in normalen
zeiten so zu sagen dass ich den heiligen
leib christi auch empfangen für jemand
der krank ist der sich mir anvertraut
hat in sand problem und mich gebeten hat
für ihn für sie zu beten wenn wir auch
nicht selbst diese kommunion empfangen
können so tue dass doch jemand für uns
selbst tapete ein stück auch des profis
für uns auch klar und deutlich
[Musik]
dieses lied kennen wir auch aus unserem
gesang bucher
chili und credit suisse am himmel
erklang anrufen halleluja christus der
herr triumphiert halleluja
[Musik]
er hat den tod am kreuz überwunden
halleluja
jetzt ist er in seinen himmel hinauf
gestiegen
hollywood ja
[Musik]
christus lebt jetzt mitten unter uns
halleluja auch wir werden mit ihm
auferstehen
halleluja
[Musik]
der papst wird jetzt gleich mit dem
schlussgebet und einem segen so ist es
geplant diese ostermesse beschließen
wird dann im petersdom in die nähe des
petrus grabes gehen um dann von dort
seine osterbotschaft zu verkünden und
den segen urbi et orbi spenden
lasst uns beten allmächtiger gott du
hast deine kirche durch die österlichen
geheimnisse neues leben geschenkt
bewahre und beschütze uns in deiner
liebe und für uns der herrlichkeit der
auferstehung durch christus unseren
herrn armen herrn sei mit euch und
wieder im geiste der name des herrn sei
gepriesen von nun an ein bisschen
ewigkeit unsere hilfe ist im namen des
herrn der himmel und erde erschaffen hat
es segne euch der allmächtige gott der
vater und der sohn und der heilige geist
armen
[Musik]
field hin in frieden halleluja halleluja
dank sei gott dem herrn halleluja
halleluja
[Musik]
der gottesdienst endet mit einem gruß an
die gottesmutter
regina caeli
laetare himmelskönigin frohlocke
der papst begibt sich dazu zu einer
marien ikone der salus populi romani
[Musik]
die himmelskönigin frohlocke halleluja
denn er den du zu tragen würde ich fast
halleluja ist erstanden wie er sagte
halleluja
mit gott für uns maria
[Musik]
diese marien ikone salus populi romani
heil des römischen volkes ist ein witz
an technisches bildnis das von vielen
römern in besonderen nöten besucht wird
und in der römischen marien basilika
santa maria maggiore hofft bewahrt wird
das kreuz das während des gottesdienstes
zu sehen war ist das sogenannte
pestkreuz das in den letzten wochen am
vatikan bei den zeremonien von papst
franziskus immer eine zentrale rolle
spielte ist normalerweise in einer
kirche san marcello all corso im herzen
der altstadt
dort hatte franziskus bereits mitte märz
besucht und es dann zum petersdom holen
lassen
im 16 jahrhundert wurde es während der
pest den prozessionen durch home
getragen
dieses kreuz allerdings ist auf dem
großen baldachin der über dem papstaltar
steht 49 meter hoch ist dieses kreuz
dieser baldachin steht direkt über dem
grab in dem der tradition nach petrus
begraben wurde
der petersdom ist ja eigentlich eine
grabeskirche die eigentliche
bischofskirche des bischofs von rom des
papstes ist die lateranbasilika
[Musik]
es wird jetzt vor dem papstaltar alles
vorbereitet damit franziskus seiner
osterbotschaft verkünden kann wenn es
richtig gesehen habe ist das hauptportal
des petersdomes geöffnet so dass der
papst wenn er dann nachher spricht einen
freien blick hat durch den lehrern
petersdom auf den lehrern petersplatz
die prachtstraße via della conciliazione
hinunter bis zur engelsburg
das ist die sogenannte kathedra von der
vorhin schon die rede war in dieses
diese bronze ist ein holzstuhl
eingearbeitet
von gian lorenzo bernini im siebzehnten
jahrhundert geschaffen
[Musik]
für den papst sind diese tage sicherlich
sehr ungewöhnlich franziskus ist ein
mensch der eigentlich die nähe zu den
menschen sucht der gerade den menschen
den gläubigen nah sein will karabag was
bedeutet es für einen priester in diesen
tagen in denen eigentlich die nähe die
man ja sonst sucht zu den gläubigen
nicht möglich ist
das ist schwierig denn ein priester ist
ja eigentlich auch unterwegs mit der
papst zu den menschen mit den menschen
ich habe auch diese tage die
gottesdienste gehalten mit ganz wenigen
menschen zusammen und das hat mir was
gefehlt trotzdem darf ich sagen dass ich
viele menschen in meinen gedanken ja
auch während der eucharistiefeier ja
aber auch in meinem herzen dabei hatte
trotzdem ist das ein mangel
sie haben vorhin gesagt eigentlich wären
sie morgen auf dem petersplatz mit einer
pilgergruppe und hätten
denn das mittagsgebet mit dem papst
gebeten am ostermontag das bedeutet dass
jetzt da nicht sein zu können
es ist schade wir waren eine kleine
gruppe die sich aufmachen wollte nach
oben die tage genießen wollte und jetzt
da nicht hin zu können
das ist schon ein mangel wenn man jetzt
auch das bild hier sieht von den
drohenden petrus schade muss ich sagen
auch dass uns das verwehrt ist in diesem
jahr aber wir haben es aufgeschoben und
nicht aufgehoben
[Musik]
die
die statue des petrus steht in der nähe
des petrus grabs diese bronzestatue aus
dem dreizehnten jahrhundert der ein oder
andere der schon in rom war oder die
schon in rom wartet vielleicht wissen
dass der rechte fuß ganz abgeflacht ist
von dieser bronzestatue viele pilger die
in den petersdom kommen den fuß berühren
und ist verbinden diese berührung mit
einem bittgebet petrus möge bei gott in
den anliegen des berührenden eintreten
oder sich schlicht auch einen segen
erhoffen und erwünschen durch diese
berührung
[Musik]
wir sehen hier ein relief das kreuz jesu
das in einem der eckpfeiler die um den
großen papstaltar herum die kuppel des
michelangelo tragen im petersdom
es gibt in jedem dieser eckpfeiler eine
kapelle in der hier angedeutet gerade
eben das kreuz in der eine kreuzreliquie
aufbewahrt werden sollen
es dauert noch etwas bis haus franziskus
die liturgischen gewänder gewechselt hat
normalerweise hat er beim ruby seinen
normalen weißen talarek ein liturgisches
gewand zum segen reicht ihnen dann der
zeremonien meister und senioren marini
hier begleitet eine stola
aber ansonsten ist der papst in seinem
üblichen weißen teller
[Musik]
der papst verließ nun die osterbotschaft
seine veredelt liebe brüder und
schwestern vor ostern heute erklingt
überall in der welt die botschaft der
kirche jesus christus ist auferstanden
er ist wahrhaft auferstanden wie eine
neue flamme erstrahlte diese gute
nachricht in der nacht in der nacht
einer welt die bereits mit epochalen
herausforderungen zu kämpfen hatte und
nun von einer pandemie bedrängt wird die
unsere große menschheitsfamilie auf eine
harte probe stellt in dieser nacht ist
nun die stimme der kirche erklingen
er lebt der herr meine hoffnung
es geht hier um eine andere art der
ansteckung die von herz zu herz
übertragen wird denn jedes menschliche
herz sehen diese gute nachricht es ist
die ansteckung der hoffnung erlebt der
hoffnung das ist kein zauberspruch
welcher unsere probleme verschwinden
lässt
nein die auferstehung christi ist etwas
anderes
sie ist der sieg der liebe über die
wurzel des bösen der leiden und tod
nicht umgehen sondern durchquert und dem
abgrund einen weg öffnen und damit böse
sind gutes verwandelt dies ist ein
exklusives kennzeichen der macht gottes
der auferstanden und der gekreuzigte
sind der selber nicht zwei verschiedene
an seinem verherrlichten leib trägt er
unauslöschlich die male der kreuzigung
die wunden die zu locken der hoffnung
geworden sind wir richten unseren blick
auf ihm er möge die wunden der geplagten
menschheit heilen
in meinen gedanken bin ich heute vor
allem bei denjenigen die unmittelbar vom
corona virus betroffen sind bei den
kranken den verstorbenen und den
familien die um ihre angehörigen trauern
von denen sie sich bisweilen nicht
einmal verabschieden konnten
der herr des lebens nehme die
verstorbenen auf die dawn in sein reich
und schenke denen trost und hoffnung die
sich noch in der prüfung befinden
insbesondere den alten und
alleinstehenden menschen säumen ich
denjenigen trost und die notwendige
hilfe zuteil werden zu lassen
die besonders gefährdet sind wie etwa
diejenigen die in pflegeheimen arbeiten
oder in kasernen und gefängnissen leben
für viele ist es ein recht einsames
osterfest inmitten von trauer und
verschiedene nöten die von der pandemie
herrühren von körperlichem leid bis hin
zu finanziellen schwierigkeiten
diese krankheit hat uns nicht nur der
gegenseitigen er beraubt sondern auch
der möglichkeit trost aus den
sakramenten zu schöpfen
insbesondere denen der eucharistie und
der versöhnung der beichte in vielen
ländern war es nicht möglich
die sakramente zu fall aber der hat uns
nicht alleine lassen
im gebet auch weiterhin vereint sind wir
gewiss dass er seine hand auf uns gelegt
hat und uns eindringlich wiederholt
fürchtet euch nicht
ich bin erstanden und ich bin immer bei
dir und hoffnung verleiht jesus der
auferstandene den ärzten sowie den
krankenschwestern und pflegern die
überall ein zeugnis der fürsorge und
liebe für ihren nächsten bis zur
erschöpfung und nicht selten bis zum
opfer der eigenen gesundheit ablegen und
allen die sich eifrig für die
gewährleistung aller dienste einsetzen
die zum gesellschaftlichen zusammenleben
notwendig sind den ordens kräften und
dem militär die in vielen ländern dazu
beigetragen haben die schwierigkeiten
und leiden der bevölkerung zu lindern
gilt unser herzlicher dank
in diesen wochen hat sich das leben von
millionen von menschen schlagartig
verändert für viele war der aufenthalt
zu hause eine gelegenheit nachzudenken
in der hektik des lebens innezuhalten
und mit ihren lieben zusammen zu sein
und ihre gesellschaft zu genießen
für viele ist es aber auch eine zeit der
sorge um eine ungewisse zukunft den
drohenden verlust eines arbeitsplatzes
und die anderen folgen die gegenwärtige
krise mit sich bringt ich ermutige alle
politisch verantwortlichen sich aktiv
für das gemeinwohl der bürger
einzusetzen
und die mittel und geräte
bereitzustellen die notwendig sind um
allen ein menschenwürdiges leben zu
ermöglichen und dann wenn es die
umstände erlauben ihnen zu helfen ihre
gewohnten täglichen aktivitäten wieder
aufzunehmen
diese zeit erlaubt keine
gleichgültigkeit
denn die ganze welt leidet und muss sich
bei der bekämpfung der pandemie
zusammenschließen der auferstandene
schenke den armen und allen die am rande
der gesellschaft leben den flüchtlingen
und obdachlosen hoffnung
mögen diese schwächsten brüder und
schwestern die die städte und
randgebiete in allen teilen der welt
bevölkern nicht auf sich allein gestellt
sein lassen nicht zu dass es ihnen an
den lebensnotwendigen dingen fehlt die
jetzt aufgrund der vielen schließungen
nur schwer zu finden sind ebenso wie
auch medikamente und eine angemessene
gesundheitsversorgung angesichts der
umstände sollten auch die
internationalen sanktionen gelockert
werden die es den betreffenden ländern
unmöglich machen ihre bürger angemessen
zu unterstützen
alle staaten sollten in die lage
versetzt werden die notwendigsten
maßnahmen in angriff zu nehmen indem die
schulden welche die bilanzen der ärmsten
länder belasten die teilweise oder sogar
ganz erlassen werden
diese zeit erlaubt keinen egoismus
denn die herausforderung vor der wir
stehen ist uns allen gemeinsam und macht
keine unterschiede
bei den vielen gebieten der welt die von
corona virus betroffen sind kommt mir
eigens in bezug auf europa folgender
gedanke nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
konnte dieser geschätzte kontinent
wieder neu erstehen
weil ein konkret spürbarer geist der
solidarität es ermöglichte die
rivalitäten der vergangenheit zu
überwinden
umso dringender ist dass gerade unter
den heutigen umständen dass diese
rivalitäten nicht wieder aufleben
sondern dass sich alle als teil einer
familie erkennen und sich gegenseitig
unterstützen
die europäische union steht heute vor
einer epochalen herausforderung die von
der nicht nur ihre zukunft sondern die
der ganzen welt abhängt lasst uns nicht
die gelegenheit versäumen einen weiteren
beweis der solidarität zu erbringen
auch wenn wir dazu neue wege ein als
alternative bleibt sonst nur ein
egoismus der einzelinteressen und die
versuchung in die vergangenheit
zurückzukehren und das risiko in kauf zu
nehmen dass das friedliche zusammenleben
und die entwicklung künftiger
generationen auf eine harte probe
gestellt werden
diese zeit erlaubt keine spaltung möge
christus unser friede diejenigen
erleuchten die in den konflikten
verantwortung tragen so dass sie den mut
haben
dem aufruf zu einem globalen und
sofortigen waffenstillstand in allen
teilen der welt zu folgen
das ist nicht der zeitpunkt waffen zu
produzieren und zu verkaufen
die mittel müssen genutzt werden um
leben zu retten und mittel gegen die
pandemie zu entwickeln
der lange und blutige krieg in syrien
der konflikt im jemen und die spannungen
im irak sowie im libanon müssen endlich
ein ende
dies ist hoffentlich auch der zeitpunkt
an dem israelis und palästinenser
endlich wieder den dialog aufnehmen um
eine stabile und dauerhafte lösung zu
finden
die beiden ein leben in frieden
ermöglicht das leid der menschen in der
ost ukraine muss aufhören
man setze den terroranschlägen gegen die
so viele unschuldige menschen in
verschiedenen ländern afrikas verübt
werden ein ende
diese zeit erlaubt kein vergessen die
krise in der wir uns augenblicklich
befinden lassen uns nicht die
zahlreichen anderen nöte vergessen unter
denen viele menschen leiden
der herr des lebens zeige den menschen
in asien und afrika seine nähe
die schwere humanitäre krisen
durchmachen wie etwa in der region kabul
delgado im norden mosambiks erwärme die
herzen der vielen menschen die aufgrund
von krieg und hungersnot auf der flucht
sind
er beschützt die vielen migranten und
flüchtlinge unter denen sich zahlreiche
kinder befinden und die unter
unerträglichen bedingungen leben
insbesondere in libyen und an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze
ich möchte auch die insel lesbos nicht
vergessen
er ermögliche dass man in venezuela
konkrete und sofortige lösungen findet
die darauf abzielen internationale hilfe
für die bevölkerung zu ermöglichen
die unter der schweren politischen
sozioökonomischen und gesundheitlichen
situation leitet liebe brüder und
schwestern gleichgültigkeit egoismus
spaltung und vergessen sind wahrlich
nicht die worte die wir in dieser zeit
hören wir wollen sie aus allen zeiten
verbannen
sie scheinen besonders dann die oberhand
zu bekommen wenn angst und tod in uns
dominieren
das heißt wenn wir den herren in unseren
herzen und in unserem leben nicht ziehen
lassen der den tod bereits besiegt hat
und uns den weg zum ewigen heil eröffnet
hat vertreibe die schatten unserer armen
menschheit und er führe uns hin zu dem
herrlichen tag der keinen abend kennt
mit diesen reflexionen möchte ich ihnen
allen frohe ostern wünschen
es folgt nun der segen urbi ad astra
kündigten an ab und erklärt dass dieser
segen verbunden es mit einem ablass für
all diejenigen die über die sozialen
kommunikationsmittel fernsehen und radio
verbunden sind fügt hinzu dass der
allmächtige konnte der kirche den papst
möglichst lange erhalten möge
sein die apostel die heiligen apostel
petrus und paulus auf deren macht und
fürsprache wir vertrauen für uns beim
herrn einzutreten
auf die fürsprache und aufgrund der
verdienste der seligen allzeit
jungfräulichen gottesmutter maria des
heiligen erzengels michael des heiligen
johannes des täufers der heiligen
apostelfürsten petrus und paulus und
allerheiligen schenke euch der
allmächtige gott sein erbarmen und jesus
christus für euch nach der vergebung all
eure sünden zum ewigen leben
der allmächtige und barmherzige herr
gewehre euch nach dass vergebung und
verzeihung all eure sündern erfülle euch
mit wahrhafter und fruchtbringende reue
schenke euch ein immer buß fertiges hass
und die fülle des lebens schneiden trost
durch den heiligen geist und ausdauer in
guttenberg bei euch allezeit armen
ein schlichter und stiller segen urbi et
orbi
an ostern 2020
[Applaus]
keine menschenmengen keine
nationalhymnen kein blumenschmuck ein
lehrer petersdom
[Musik]
franziskus hat angesichts der weltweiten
corona krise zu internationalem zusammen
gehalt aufgerufen
die menschheit werde durch die pandemie
auf eine harte probe gestellt so der
papst gerade eben in seiner
osterbotschaft diese zeit erlaube weder
gleichgültigkeit noch egoismus wieder
spaltungen noch ein vergessen anderer
notlagen
[Musik]
besonders europa mahnte der papst zu
einem spürbaren geist der solidarität
[Musik]
diese solidarität spüren in diesen tagen
viele menschen durch große und kleine
werke der nächstenliebe hilfen durch
nachbarn durch freunde
[Musik]
es ist ein besonderes osterfest
mit einem besonderen mit einer
besonderen ostermesse mit einem
besonderen
segen des papstes urbi et orbi der stadt
und dem erdkreis fahrerfeld was nehmen
sie mit aus dieser zeremonie ich bin
noch beeindruckt vom kreuzweg von den
aussagen der menschen aber die
schlichtheit und vor allen dingen der
papst sagt die mehr herz und sieht
global
das ist für mich immer wieder auch macht
mich froh und lässt mich an gestand
feiern
das wünschen wir allen zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern ein besonderes ostern
2020 aber hoffentlich für alle von ihnen
ein schönes und doch frohe ostern 2020
vielen dank dass sie mit dabei waren bei
der ostermesse und dem urbi et orbi mit
papst franziskus es verabschieden sich
jürgen erbacher ja und pfarrer heinz
volk
alles gute ihnen mit den glocken von st
peter
verabschieden wir uns
[Musik]
[Applaus]